Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
Nadas en el mar cuando
algo roza tu pierna.
Sientes un hormigueo
y te das cuenta de que
te ha picado una medusa.
¿Cómo pueden estas hermosas criaturas
gelatinosas causar tanto dolor?
Las medusas son suaves
porque son 95 % agua
y están compuestas
por una sustancia gelatinosa
translúcida llamada mesoglea.
Sus cuerpos tan delicados están cargados
de miles de células venenosas
urticantes llamadas cnidocitos
para defensa y captura de presas.
Incluso las medusas bebé,
del tamaño de un borrador,
tienen la capacidad de picar.
Las medusas larval, ephyrae, parecen
flores diminutas que laten en el mar.
Al crecer adquieren forma de paraguas
con una campana en la parte superior
y tentáculos que cuelgan de
su borde en el extremo inferior.
La especie más grande de
medusas, la melena de león,
llegan a tener tentáculos
de hasta 40 metros,
más largos que una ballena azul.
La mayoria de las células urticantes
están ubicadas en los tentáculos
aunque en algunas especies están
presentes en las campanas, también.
El veneno se eyecta por un nematocisto,
un filamento hueco con forma de látigo,
que se encuentra enrollado
bajo alta presión osmótica.
Cuando los estímulos mecánicos o químicos
activan un disparador externo,
la tapa de la cápsula se abre
y se rellena de agua de mar.
Esto provoca la eyectión
de una púa microscópica,
que penetra e inyecta
veneno en su víctima.
La descarga de nematocistos se produce
en menos de una millonésima de segundo
y es uno de los procesos biomecánicos
más rápidos de la naturaleza.
Los nematocistos pueden envenenar
incluso después de la muerte de la medusa
por eso es importante eliminar
los tentáculos adheridos a la piel.
Un enjuague con vinagre por lo general
dejará inactivos a los nematocistos.
El agua de mar también puede ayudar
a eliminar los nematocistos residuales.
Pero no uses agua dulce ya que cualquier
cambio en el equilibrio salino
altera la presión osmótica
externa del cnidocito
y hará que el nematocisto se active.
Por eso orinar en la zona afectada,
un remedio popular común,
puede hacer más mal que bien, en función
de la composición de la orina.
La mayoría de las picaduras
de medusas son dolorosas,
pero algunas pueden ser mortales.
La medusa caja del Indo-Pacífico,
también llamada avispa de mar,
libera veneno que puede causar la
contracción de los músculos cardíacos
y la muerte fulminante en grandes dosis.
Hay un antídoto, pero el veneno
es de acción rápida
y por eso se necesita una
intervención médica inmediata.
A pesar de la impresionante
potencia de sus tentáculos,
las medusas no son invencibles.
Sus células urticantes no son rival
para depredadores de piel gruesa
como la tortuga laúd y los peces luna.
Estos depredadores tienen adaptaciones
que impiden a las resbaladizas medusas
escapar luego de ser engullidas:
espinas orientadas hacia atrás en
la boca y el esófago de la tortuga
y dientes recurvados detrás
de las mejillas del pez luna.
Incluso las pequeñas larvas de langosta
se aferran a la campana de una medusa
y dan un paseo,
comiendo la gelatina mientras preservan
su propia energía para crecer.
Los pececitos ágiles usan a las medusas
como arrecifes móviles por protección,
escondiendose entre
sus tentáculos sin tocarlos.
Los nudibranquios o las babosas
de mar, cubiertas de limo protector,
pueden aprovechar las defensas de
la medusa comiendose sus cnidocitos
y transfiriéndolos a sus tentáculos
especializados para un uso posterior,
como armas contra
sus propios depredadores.
Incluso los humanos algún día podríamos
beneficiarnos de la picadura de medusas.
Los científicos manipulan los cnidocitos
para conseguir suministrar fármacos
a base de nematocistos
que rara vez superan
al 3 % del tamaño
de una aguja de jeringa típica.
Así que, la próxima vez que
estés en el mar, ten cuidado.
Pero también, tómate un segundo
para admirar sus maravillas.